he's Chris Harrison he's the host of the
bachelor and he wanted to clear
something up he has a girlfriend he's
not engaged what the hell's wrong with
you guys why like what what group of guy
friends does that I thought you were in
love apparently you're not Chris ILC
that's nothing I would say on my show
are you opening your heart I'm here for
the right reasons I am on this journey
the corny lines that you hear Angela
have you ever used any of those in real
life no although I will say this I've
and I can say this now because I am in
love I do have a wonderful girlfriend
not engaged
breaking news okay breaking news on that
I mean boys force Harrison but you know
I have broken up before there's the
lovely lauren zima from an entry to
tonight but when i was breaking up with
someone before i thought to myself like
you know is this good TV is like is this
good like what kind of cross my mind I
was like oh my god what is wrong with
you but I live my life thinking can this
be used on the show okay so I do think
of the content it's been 20 years of
this I have maybe it's not so abnormal
but it's that shouldn't be crossing your
mind when you are breaking up with
somebody I would think that that'd be a
little disingenuous if you say to her
hey can we do it again we got to get a
reversal so they can get your crime it's
not I I need to eyes when you go down I
need to I really need to see both when
you're cry ya know when you have those
thoughts like this that's not good but
you're always around love or attempted
love yeah so you're watching this past
24/7 all the time and I would think that
would make you either go No or yeah like
I want that feeling again well it makes
me appreciate something normal and I
think that is the the normalcy and just
someone who I can have a normal
existence with and get away from the
crazy do you find that guys watch the
show but don't know what MIT they watch
they used to I feel like more and more
guys are now coming out
closet and and I think a lot of that has
to do with Howard Stern Jimmy Kimmel a
lot of these athletes NFL guys are big
fans of the show but at first it was it
was the hey like my wife kind of watches
the show I've seen it a few times now
the guys are just all in hey guys you
like if you could pick athletes who
would be ideal to have on who's single
wow I don't know who's that guy I don't
know who's single anymore
I mean cuz like it's Gronk still on the
market or Z off he's got a girlfriend
yeah that's not really it's kind like me
you know it's like yeah we could break
them up yeah you're both in love you
both oh yeah so uh let's see who else
who's single now cuz I feel like we're
losing a lot of good men out there but
what if you had well you could pick
anybody with just their personality like
are you looking as a personality based
you need a good story like it would be a
good story you know if you did an
athlete a famous face obviously someone
that you know the guys would want to be
women would want to be with that kind of
a guy it's kind of like that that George
Clooney Brad Pitt guy where guys want to
hang girls want to be with him who's
that guy in sports who would that be
right now how about Baker Mayfield is I
think he might need down there if he was
single
Baker me a dumpster fire dak Prescott
Jared golf Patrick mahomes like you
could have the Cueto Jer Jer would be
great he's very quiet though he's only
quiet reserved guy does that ever work
on The Bachelor yeah cuz it's not really
as much about the guys as it is about
the women so Jared might actually be
good I know Joe he's a he would might be
a really good one who else deck yeah
Jack Prescott Zach would he do it for 30
million or would he turn it down no I
don't know are you surprised at that yes
and no I mean could he get more but yeah
yes but only from the Cowboys who else
is gonna pay him 30 million yeah I mean
that makes him what number six on the
list is Pete quarterbacks
yeah I don't know what the big with Matt
Ryan I think you put some right around
Matt Ryan no does he have the same
resume as Matt Ryan no maybe he has more
upside to being young but I don't know I
think thirty millions of pretty nice
chunk of change for a year's work he's
Chris Harrison he is the bachelor and
bachelorette host
I guess you got yeah there are punches
thrown tomorrow night yes rattler and
paradise punches are thrown okay
by two models okay men okay male models
what happened so these are two guys
Jordan and Christian are on the beach
they're in paradise
and somehow clay is involved clays one
of our one of our kind of football guys
and things get heated and these two
models they go off it was like a bad sue
lander and what happened did you get
involved
I oddly enough no i sat there so this is
really interesting so the the control
truck which is where I'm watching all
this go down is I don't know it's like
say quarter-mile away about 400 yards up
this hill so I'm sitting there watching
and this other executive producer
sitting next to me and as soon as it
happened he runs out like he was shot
out of a cannon to go break this up you
know Security's there producers are
there and I just sat there watching why
first of all why are we breaking it up
let him go yes lean yeah it's Mexico I
don't like there's any rules to this No
so let's see these two models of what
are they gonna do scratch each other to
death I'm surprised that they'd be
thrown punches
maybe in their arm like hitting you in
the arm was very zoo later like no no
everything shoulders in below yes keep
it in nothing in the face but no I did
got serious and and I don't want to give
away the end of the fight but one of the
models wheelie through the guy like
impressively took him down like octagon
style great takedown and what was this
over it was over a pinata Dan of course
how many fights were started that way
truly the fight was over a pinata it
goes deeper than the pinata
there was a woman involved but the the
pinata that broke the camel's back
pinata how much there's part of you has
to show great restraint because do you
want content yeah in all seriousness we
had to break it up and we stopped it
quickly before it got too serious
because we can't have that and yes you
want the emotion you want these these
people to give you good story but that's
not something we can tolerate so we had
to break it up unfortunately I would
have let it go a little bit longer
that's just me Jimmy Garoppolo for the
bachelor Oh he'd be good oh I'm kidding
it's a home run up the road now yeah the
home run yeah yeah he's so handsome Tom
Brady had him traded there's something
in Brady's contract he has to be the
best-looking guy Tom Brady ever fears
anybody in the handsome category I think
I don't know I think he worried a little
bit about Jimmy G interesting not his
skills he's not gonna replace me that
guy's too damn handsome I think he was a
little nervous about Jimmy G on the
field too
yeah I think so that's funny but you
know when you see these shows and
everybody gets together and you're not
quite sure what's going to happen have
you ever had something where you go
nothing to happen like think that's not
your goal is to get something to write
what's scary when you when you produce a
show and you create a show you know it's
a it's a game show or what have you
there's a beginning middle and end
there's a there's a there's a goal
you're going to reach and this will have
say say survivor or Dancing with the
Stars whatever it is it's a bit of a
game show there is something you're
gonna get to well with with bachelor in
bachelor in paradise you have a goal
which is a relationship but you're
really left up to freewill you don't
know if you're gonna get that
relationship and so every time you go
into paradise which is on tonight and
tomorrow night you hope
I mean you hope these people are gonna
hook up you hope you're gonna get a
relationship you hope you're gonna get
something but you're really not
guaranteed it really is a scary way to
go into a show how did you know that you
had the skills for this really what I
didn't know what skill said it is any
discernible skills because I would have
a hard time not gone shut up it is hard
I think you know being a dad and being
of the age I finally am I think I've
learned some patience but sometimes it
is hard not to just grab them by the
scruff of the neck and say come on man
pull it together or to these young
ladies same thing of what are you doing
but watching this unfold is fascinating
I think it's one of the great things
about the
is you are watching we're all watching
something we've all been through we've
all been that young man young woman
who's made those dumb mistakes and for a
lot of us we still do we still make
really dumb mistakes and so to watch
other people go through something we can
really relate to is fascinating but how
much research do you how much homework
do you do do you investigate everybody
because the this last dude had like
three girlfriends and I'm honestly
really more worried about my fantasy
drafts and in golf and in soccer and
football and all that than I am the show
I leave that up to the pros but the
tough thing about honestly the bachelor
in bachelor you can do a background
check
legally that's easy to dive into to
someone have a felony or something like
that the big picture stuff is easy it's
like you guys just buried me does he
have a girlfriend is he engaged what you
know there's stuff that is in that gray
area of does he have a girlfriend well
all these people are young and
good-looking so they've all dated how
long ago is too long how short is too
sure well he broke up with her here well
according to her they're not broken up
there's no way to really tell so you
kind of have to take people for the you
know at their word to a certain degree
where you how surprised were you that
this guy had so Jed is who we're talking
about so Jed came back and he he's a
Nashville country singer he did a dog
jingle and then now he's he brought a
guitar too here's the thing ladies when
a guy shows up at your proposal with a
guitar run yeah but he's auditioning for
Nashville right yeah he doesn't care
about oh yeah he showed up with a guitar
and he's he admitted as much that he
came on to actually promote his career
than if he fell in love with Hannah and
then this this girlfriend came out of
the woodwork and you and again you don't
know how if she's coming for her 15
minutes of fame if it's real so it's
really hard to figure it out but that
again the show has never been predicated
on the fact that it guarantees that it's
successful you have to figure that out
as the bachelor the Bachelorette you
know Jimmy Garofalo has got to figure it
out you have to read the defense you
have to figure it out all those corners
cheating in how many weddings have you
been invited to a lot yeah I just missed
one
last night actually for to be here no I
was working working on another project
welcome Rhode Island we would have been
crossing each other no so Ashley and
Jared got married from our show they met
on the beaches of well they met on the
show and then in Paradise they fell in
love and they ended up getting married
last night so but got a dozen to you
know 15 weddings we've had off the show
what do you bring as a wedding gift I
just I go on to the registry and and
that is the tough part because obviously
of Who I am
I just have to tell my assistant just
pick the most expensive thing just do it
oh yeah yeah just wait you just put it
in the budget
well because it's like it's so it's like
when you go out right yeah and so if
you're kind of obscure and no one knows
you yeah you leave your typical 20% oh
yeah but if they're like Dan Patrick
love the Dan Patrick show you're great
that's at least 5% more exactly right
and I as soon as a waiter does that I
might yeah I'm dead yeah they're like
why I'm like well now I gotta I am I
have a fear of being judged oh I have a
fear of not like as soon as I leave I
want that waiter to go wow he's really
generous he's a nice guy
so you judge for a living yeah on The
Bachelor and so I feel that and so when
when they're opening up their wedding
gifts I want them to say damn that's a
nice pressure cooker Harrison good guy
when we're steaming some chicken that's
our guy I think a Chris Harrison yeah
once again he is in love he's opened his
heart but he's not engaged she's a great
woman I'm in love how long you been in
love we've been together for a year
oh yeah okay it's a good run if your
kids kids are signing off on Josh and
Taylor are on board of course my son is
17 going into a senior year so I can
tell you how much he cares about my life
zero yeah a big zero so yeah we're we're
launching into our senior year we're
doing the college thing and I got a
daughter is going into her sophomore
year it's crazy
and so 10:00 tomorrow night tonight
tomorrow night
ABC bachelor in paradise tomorrow
night's really the big pin
Yatta that's when the fistic oh that's
the quinceanera that's where it all goes
down yeah it's good if you want to watch
two models go at it
he keeps saying models a little too much
for me like I wouldn't watch two guys
fight but these are two models so
they're good-looking guys who can't fire
it's it's written models pretty good
yeah
McLovin you got one question for Chris
and then that's it my wife has been
texting me all interview and I don't
think you're allowed to say but when are
you gonna announce the next Bachelor
we're gonna wait until towards the end a
bachelor in paradise because we have
some guys that are there including Big
Mike who arrives tonight tonight or
tomorrow night Big Mike shows up he's
obviously one of the contenders so we're
gonna let this play out see if anybody
pops off paradise and then obviously
with with Tyler who went off and kind of
dated Hannah and then he ended up on a
date with Gigi Hadid I know in New York
so it's like okay is he gonna be the
batteries again a date Gigi Hadid it's a
win-win I could really see the day
that's this this setup this guy isn't
set up is tough Chris will you tell me
afterwards if you know can you just tell
me off-camera not that what what tell
yeah you know who it's good yeah you can
trust us to keep your safe know who it's
gonna be okay you you can tell me I'll
tell you guys in three two one
well it's Chris Harrison the bachelor
tonight and tomorrow night fist will fly
a pinata gets broken open and somebody
opens their heart to love you just
summed up my entire life it's great to
see you good to see you for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]